und schuldig im Knast ein Albtraum für
Murat ackel wurde er brutale Realität er
saß in U-Haft für ein Verbrechen dass er
nie begangen hatte
ich war mir sicher hundertprozent das
ist nur eine Dinger so wie sozusagen
eine Schikane mehr nicht oder dieser
Druck weil ich wusste genau das von mein
inneren ich bin unschuldig 30 Jahre
lebte und arbeitete der kurdische
Familienvater unbescholten in
Deutschland
2019 nimmt aktuell an einer kurdischen
Demonstration teil die Behörden glauben
er gehören zur verbotenen Organisation
PKK ackel wird in die Türkei ausgewiesen
als er zurück nach Deutschland flieht
wird er verhaftet er landet in
Untersuchungshaft weil die
Staatsanwaltschaft Fluchtgefahr wittert
Willkür meint sein Anwalt
er hat sich den Behörden und dem
Verfahren zur Verfügung gestellt nach
drei Monaten dann von einem Tag auf den
anderen Fluchtgefahr anzunehmen das ist
absurd
Nachfragen von Frontal lässt die
Staatsanwaltschaft führt unbeantwortet
fest steht nach monatelangem Verfahren
spricht das Landgericht Nürnberg führt
den Familienvater frei die
Untersuchungshaft war rechtswidrig so
steht es auf juristendeutsche Urteil
zu Unrecht geht das Amtsgericht vom
Vorliegen eines Haftgrundes aus
zu den maßgeblichen Umständen gehören
die Persönlichkeit des Beschuldigten
seine Lebensverhältnisse vor diesem
Hintergrund ist die Fluchtgefahr
vorliegend nicht zu bejahen kann es in
mein Leben lang nicht mehr vergessen das
wird wie ein Drama für mich bleiben es
kann sein 18 Tagen sein es kann sein
jahrelang aber das wird für immer
das kannst du nicht vergessen Murat
aktuell ist kein Einzelfall eine Studie
kam zu dem Ergebnis in vier von fünf
Fällen ist die Untersuchungshaft
unrechtmäßig
Thomas Fischer war Vorsitzender Richter
am Bundesgerichtshof er erklärt den
Missstand so es ist doch vielfach zum
beobachten dass sehr viele Menschen
meinen und fordern und dafür sind dass
die Untersuchungshaft erstens schnell
zweitens oft und drittens hart sein soll
damit der Beschuldigte der dann jeweils
in Haft genommen ist wenigstens schon
ein Teil der Strafe sozusagen vorab
verbüßen muss das hat natürlich mit dem
mit der Unschuldsvermutung und den
Grundsätzen die in der
Strafprozessordnung und auch in der fünf
Verfassung geben Grundgesetz stehen
wenig zu tun aber es ist eine Stimmung
die sich breit gemacht hat und wie alle
Stimmungen ist auch die Justiz nicht
völlig frei davon von ihr beeinflusst zu
werden
Untersuchungshaft ist ein schwerer
Eingriff in die Grundrechte sie bedeutet
Freiheitsentzug ohne Urteil trotz
Unschuldsvermutung
sie wird angeordnet um zu verhindern
dass Angeklagte fliehen Beweise
vernichten oder weitere Straftaten
begehen und kommt immer öfter zum
Einsatz
seit 2014 ist die Zahl der
Untersuchungshäftlinge in Deutschland um
11 Prozent auf fast 30.000 pro Jahr
gestiegen obwohl die Zahl der Straftaten
im selben Zeitraum zurückging
15 Jahre hat Thomas gali
Justizvollzugsanstalten geleitet er ist
überzeugt U-Haft werde zu oft zu Unrecht
angeordnet
in vielen Fällen ist die
Untersuchungshaft nach meiner Erfahrung
und Überzeugung unverhältnismäßig da
wird ein Schaden angerichtet der nicht
notwendig wäre und der Staaten Stück
weit dann selber zum Täter wird
doch viele Staatsanwälte sehen das
offenbar anders
dieser Unternehmer wir nennen den Daniel
richtet für seine Kunden Webshops ein
verdient er mit gutes Geld plötzlich
steht die Polizei vor seiner Tür er wird
verhaftet und kommt in Untersuchungshaft
der Vorwurf Betrug
das kam wie aus heiterem Himmel ich
hatte mir nichts vorzuwerfen und morgens
um sechs Uhr hämmert es gegen die Tür
vier maskierte haben mich mitgenommen
ich erinnere mich noch im Bus wurden
dann Witze gerissen nach Stadelheim
kommt man schnell aber umso schwerer
wieder raus
die Staatsanwaltschaft wirft Daniel und
lautere Geschäftsmethoden vor Daniel
Weiß das Strick zurück das Verfahren
läuft ein Urteil ist nicht in Sicht
13 Monate sitzt Daniel in
Untersuchungshaft für ein Verbrechen
dass er bestreitet und für das ihm im
Falle seiner Schuld gar kein Gefängnis
sondern maximal eine Bewährungsstrafe
droht
ich möchte nicht behaupten dass alle
Mandanten unschuldigen Untersuchungshaft
sitzen das ist definitiv nicht der Fall
aber die Kritik macht daran fest dass
der Rechtsstaat sich ja daran messen
lassen muss dass er in den Extremfällen
funktioniert und das hat hier versagt
inzwischen hat das Gericht seine
Freilassung angeordnet auf Nachfrage von
Frontal hält das zuständige Gericht die
13 Monate U-Haft dennoch für
verhältnismäßig
insgesamt würde es sicherlich der Justiz
nicht schaden wenn sie zugestehen würde
dass sie auch mal Fehler gemacht hat
aber das habe ich bisher noch nie erlebt
Daniel fühlt sich bis heute als Knacki
ist stigmatisiert während der Haft in
Stadelheim hat er nicht nur die Geburt
seiner Tochter verpasst auch den Suizid
eines Mitgefangenen musste er miterleben
sie sehen Vorsicht die nackte Wand sie
können nicht rausschauen weil das
Fenster nicht auf Augenhöhe ist und sie
starren 23 Stunden am Tag eine nackte
Wand an natürlich werden dann Leute
depressiv begehen Suizid oder sind
verzweifelt
tatsächlich ist die Zahl der Suizide im
Gefängnissen dramatisch gestiegen allein
2020 nahmen sich 77 Menschen im Knast
das Leben viele davon in
Untersuchungshaft das hat Gründe die
Untersuchungshaft ist viel härter die
Bedingungen sind viel härter als in der
Strafhaft in der Untersuchungshaft ist
der Kontakt mit Menschen außerhalb der
Anstalt sehr stark reduziert es finden
keine
Behandlungsangebote statt so dass sie
dann tatsächlich faktisch auf 23 Stunden
einfach eingesperrt sind und dann eine
Stunde ihren Hofgang absolvieren und das
muss man sich bewusst machen für jemand
der als unschuldig als unschuldig gilt
Berlin JVA Moabit 2020 hat es hier vier
Tote in Gewahrsam gegeben einer war der
Untersuchungshäftling fair hat mayouf
ihm wurde Taschendiebstahl vorgeworfen
am 23 juli 2020 steckte der psychisch
labile Mann seine Zelle in Brand wir
sprechen wir Skype mit KS der im selben
Zellen tragt wie mayouf Einsatz
mal Lächeln im Gesicht gehabt ja
Handtuch ganz normal
geredet und so ja
irgendwann war er halt der Moment wo man
halt gesehen hat dass er sich halt
Verletzungen zugezogen hat ja auf
Bauchhöhe Höhe
da wollen wir dann halt so ein bisschen
stutzig im Fall my yout hatte die
zuständige Richterin die Haftanstalt
explizit auf die Suizidgefahr
hingewiesen in einem Protokoll heißt es
der Angeschuldigte teilte mit er habe
starke Depressionen und möchte einem
Arzt vorgeführt werden
doch der Hinweis der Richterin ist von
der Haftanstalt wir uns die Berliner
Justiz schreibt übersehen worden
ich bin ganz sicher dass er noch noch am
Leben wäre ohne ohne die Uhr Haft seine
Depressionen und sein Vorbringen wurden
ignoriert und das hat natürlich dann zu
dem schließlichen suizidalen Geschehen
beigetragen
fest steht wer hat mal Juf hat seine
Zelle in Brand gesteckt und starb an den
Folgen einer Rauchgasvergiftung doch
Einzelheiten der Todesumstände werfen
Fragen auf
wenigen Minuten nachdem der Rauch eben
entdeckt wurde bestanden da mehrere
Werte vor der Tür von Hermann new vor
der verschlossenen Zellentür und haben
entschieden diese nicht zu öffnen die
Tür wurde erst 27 Minuten später
geöffnet dann von der von der Feuerwehr
und dann konnte nur noch der Tod von
Herrn majuf festgestellt werden der
ehemalige Mithäftling KS wirft den Wert
dann vor nicht geholfen zu haben es gibt
zwei Zeugen einer visuell und einer
durch durch hören dass die Bediensteten
während seine Zelle brannte er um Hilfe
geschrieben hat und auf die
tourengejammert hat nächsten unternommen
haben
Fachleute der JVA Moabit den
Untersuchungshäftling mayouf im Stich
gelassen
gegenüber frontal erklärt ein
justizprecher
versuche den Betroffenen durch die
geschlossene haftraumtür anzusprechen
blieben ohne Resonanz und weiter die
Rettung des Betroffenen war zusätzlich
durch eine von ihm im türeingangsbereich
aufgestellte und in brandgesetzte
Barrikade aus hölzernem haftrauminventar
erschwert
Rechtsanwalt fordert nun Ermittlungen
gegen die Justizbeamten wegen
unterlassener Hilfeleistung wenn Herr
majufje einen deutschen Pass gehabt
hätte ein eine Meldeanschrift
und
ein Arbeitsverhältnis hätte vorweisen
können wäre er sicherlich nicht
inhaftiert worden
fest steht in deutschen
Untersuchungshaftanstalten sitzen vor
allem arme Menschen und Ausländer hinter
Gittern nicht selten zu Unrecht und
bevor ihre Schuld bewiesen wurde